the Wednesday night movie will not be
seen tonight so that we may bring you
the following color telecast to the 40th
annual awards of the Academy of Motion
Picture Arts and Sciences
the 40th annual Academy Awards show
guess who's coming to dinner in the heat
of the night one of the highlights of
Academy Awards night is the arrival of
glittering stars you've seen Sonny and
Cher this is Carol Channing and Karl
Malden beauteous Natalie Wood greer
garson
an all-time favorites Shirley Jones with
husband Jack Casady Rosalind Russell
Audrey Hepburn
Magnificent Raquel Welch
Paul Newman with Barbara rush
and Sidney Poitier
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences and a former winner of the
Academy Award himself mr. Gregory Peck
good evening ladies and gentlemen last
Monday was the 40th anniversary of the
Academy Awards tonight we welcome you to
our presentations this has been a
fateful week in the history of our
nation we join with fellow members of
our profession and men of goodwill
everywhere in paying our profound
respects to the memory of dr. Martin
Luther King jr. society has always been
reflected in its art and one measure of
dr. King's influence on the society we
live in is that of the five films
nominated for Best Picture of the year -
dealt with the subject of understanding
between the races it was his work and
his dedication that brought about the
increasing awareness of all men that we
must unite in compassion in order to
survive the lasting memorial that we of
the motion picture community can build
dr. King is to continue making films
would celebrate the dignity of man
whatever his race or color or creed like
our society the art of film is on a
threshold of a great renaissance
everywhere in the world new and
imaginative and meaningful work is being
done the Academy applauds the recent
creation of the American Film Institute
sponsored by the National Endowment for
the Arts which has launched vital
programs to preserve our film heritage
and to sponsor work by young creators
who might not otherwise find their way
into film careers we gratefully
acknowledge as always the advances made
by our technicians and this year Academy
certificates all awarded to the
electro-optical division of the kill
morgan corporation
Panavision incorporated to Fred our
Wilson at the Samuel Goldwyn studio
sound department and to Walden Oh Watson
and the Universal City Studios sound
department for their contributions to
our technical advancement ngratulations
gentlemen
and now for our other awards the members
of the Academy have voted by secret
ballot and the tabulated results are
once again known only to the
representative of our accounting firm he
is by now one of the few constants in
Oscars ever-changing world mr. bill
Miller
Thank You mr. Peck in accordance with
the Academy rules absolute secrecy the
ballots as again been observed here's
your certificate that price waterhouse
is counted the votes and the results are
in the sealed envelopes Thank You bill
now may I check that first envelope this
one contains the name of tonight's
master of ceremonies
well that's no secret you know it so do
I let's see if Phil Miller got it right
you did thank you now once again here is
that amiable national monument who
pricks the balloons of pomposity evokes
laughter even from the targets of his
wit and adroitly displays america's
sense of humor to the world the Academy
welcomes with pride and gratitude mr.
Bob Hope
thank you very much thank you very much
and thank you president thank you you
sure that's Arthur freed amazing what
makeup can do anyway ladies and
gentlemen here we are once again welcome
to the Academy Awards or as as it's
known at my house Passover
I just want to say about the delay of
two days it didn't affect me but it's
been tough on the nominees how would you
like to spend two days in the crouch we
also voted the special Oscar for valor
to the ABC programming department they
just committed mass Harry Caray's now
any delay really snarls up programming
and the sponsor Eastman Kodak was afraid
it would hurt their image a show that
took three days to develop
but I just to fill in the lull they had
a little earthquake out here well it was
naturally an earthquake Charlton Heston
was nominated and he was just trying to
shake up the committee ladies and
gentlemen before I begin I have an
announcement after much soul-searching I
have concluded that the awesome job of
MC should not become involved in
partisan bickering at all costs we must
preserve unity and for the unavoidable
not seek no will I accept an Oscar
and if anyone believes that I'll kill
myself we're 30 years I've been trying
to get the academy to sit down and talk
and they've always given me the same
answer they'll negotiate if I stop
bombing
I know wait I wouldn't I would have been
nominated this year but I made a picture
with Phyllis Diller and the Academy
couldn't figure out a category for us
this is it the Oscar night the crucial
time in the life of an actor when small
grievances petty dislikes and envy are
thrust aside for the opportunity for
outright hatred this is hollywood's hour
of destiny in other words two hours this
is the night we sit in judgment this is
the night we sit in judgment and may the
Late Show of ten years from now prove us
right this is our annual Pygmalion
display this is the night many an ugly
face turns beautiful and many a
beautiful face turns ugly and I'm in
there somewhere 40 years ago this affair
started as a dinner and now it's a
nationwide television show movies have
come a long ways since a dog hooker
stepped off the train 60 years ago with
a brownie camera and a letter of
introduction to Crosby
as for tonight's award I have only one
prediction to make due to the gold rain
the Oscars are made out of chopped
chicken liver
either that or they'll butter Mickey
Rooney and hand them out no there are a
lot of nervous smiling I must hurry
along there are a lot of nervous there
are a lot of nervous smiling over
friendly actors out in the audience I
don't know why the results are in the
injustice has already been compiled and
tabulated by Price Waterhouse whose
integrity integrity I can personally
vouch for they'll never get a guest shot
on let's make a deal believe me now this
is the world's most glamorous audience
what a sea of mink
ermine and diamonds looks like the Palm
Springs unemployment office it's a
beautiful audience everything matches
the men and their Donna loafer
turtlenecks and the ladies in there
Polly Bergen turtle oil and what
fabulous furs as Zsa Zsa Gabor walked in
two Chipmunks yelled Arthur Arthur
now it's a great night for the stars but
don't get the idea that success comes
without effort night after night you can
see these great stars laboring at the
factory and I wish you could see them
backstage primping backstage Jed the
velvet victorian ruffles the lace
collars the ringlets and corkscrew curls
the exotic beads and that's just the men
and i want to tell you the fans in front
of the auditorium got a lot of action
out there yellow Ferraris rolled up and
steve mcqueen got out and a white
convertible with steer horns on the
bumper drove up and dale robertson got
off in a brown Santa Monica bus stopped
and Jack Benny got off and then a big
thrilled Dean Martin rolled up no car he
just rolled up
Warren Beatty must be pretty confident
he arrived in the truck followed by Faye
Dunaway in a getaway car I got the
feeling that some of the stars went a
little too far to get attention
I didn't mind Rex Harrison arriving on a
giraffe but Dame Edith Evans at a micro
mini was a little too much a lot of new
acting talent has emerged this year
Dustin Hoffman Faye Dunaway Gene Hackman
Katharine Ross Maharishi ma Mahesh Yogi
you all know him Maharishi India's
answer to Cool Hand Luke
some of our stars went to IDIA India to
study Transcendental Meditation I went
to diction class to learn how to say
this has been a great year though for
motion pictures movies of real grown-up
and so of the kids who've been seeing a
year ago we introduced movies with dirty
words this year we brought you the
pictures to go with him today Tom Jones
would be up for a 4-h club award some of
the some of the pictures this year is so
sexy Pricewaterhouse is handing out the
names in the plain brown envelope never
on Sunday was once considered very
daring but not long ago was shown on
television with no fuss at all in fact
TV Guide simply described it as a Greek
Working Girl struggle to achieve a
six-day week yes this was the year that
Hollywood became independent of the
foreign influence we proved we could
make good dirty pictures without any
help from anybody but it's a strange
business isn't it who ever thought we'd
be making sexy pictures in Italy would
be making westerns now I was shot by
some of the nominations I really would
nominations I really was I thought
certainly that LBJ was a shoo-in for
guess who's not coming to the convention
and acting's of frustrating business
some of us beat ourselves silly with no
results in Audrey Hepburn knocks off a
nomination with her eyes shut and have
you noticed how Rod Steiger changes size
for different pictures in the pawnbroker
he was 5 foot 3 in the heat of the night
he was 6 feet I hate a man who grows for
gold
we're leaving one exit door unlatched
tonight if dr. Dolittle wins Rex
Harrison wants to rush out and break the
news to his co-stars out in the alley
and if we're giving special effects
special awards Awards for special
effects how about the one that Anne
Bancroft had on Dustin Huffman no I
thought I thought the graduate
I thought the Graduate had something to
do with a sheepskin until I saw it I was
wrong it's a story it's a story of a
college student who didn't go out for
sports until after he graduated I can't
imagine him nominating a kid like Dustin
Huffman he starred in the picture he
can't get into see and there were some
pretty sexy scenes in the Fox or as it
was originally titled any number can
play actually I don't know what the
writers have been smoking this year
Bonnie and Clyde is about happy killers
dr. Doolittle talking to animals the
graduates deduction guess who's coming
to dinner in her marriage and in the
heat of the night racism I want to tell
you I've got a great plot for my next
movie it may win an Oscar I'm gonna play
a chain gang sheriff who sticks up
sex-crazed housewives then marries a
zebra and spends his honeymoon playing
tic-tac-toe
in a moment in a moment
thank you a mobile will be handing out
the Oscars if it's safe and I sure is
sneaking up behind Warren Beatty now to
find out what the lump is his penis hip
pocket is and incidentally ladies and
gentlemen we have a new conductor for
the awards tonight mr. Elmer Bernstein
Elmer Oh Elmer has been nominated for 11
Oscar Oscars but has never won once so
you will understand if everything comes
out hearts and flowers
anyway Elmer welcome to the club he's
been through more sour grapes than the
little old winemaker but you're
wonderful